[Applause]
she put on a show she put on a show look
lucha
she's in that dress we won't mention her
dandruff
and uh and then in a coup d'etat
that went into this tear away yes
there's two outfits on top of each other
but that's quite hard to put the white
out for the top of the black i've got
it's hard it's very hard
yes in a minute and now a bit like
13 she's off to the oscar she doesn't
get her oscar by the way can i say that
in hannah
like i literally wanted to learn how to
fight after i saw that movie
i'll teach you if you want to yes good
i'm glad
and you carried that whole movie it was
like just you and so much of the movie
oh fantastic thanks yeah it's a bit of a
loving
because taylor and richard were you
ready the golden globes yeah
we actually sat next to each other oh
that's very nice
she said why are you here
uh actually i'm nominated oh really for
what
best actor in a movie yeah
no that was i really put my foot in my
mouth in that one and then
you know but then i was absolutely
freaked out because i
i met your wife carrie who and i said
it's so good to see you again
and she's like in her head i know she's
going never met this girl before
but it's because she was like my
favorite assistant district attorney
on law and order and so i literally see
her every week
it was a good night for me i was really
on
you've had a fantastic a couple of years
yeah um iron man of course
and look at that and i read in an
interview so uh
with gwyneth paltrow and she was she
wasn't sure about doing iron man number
you
phoned her to to talk her into it do you
know this story
yes if the uh the only thing i'm better
at than
uh occasionally acting is convincing
people to come do movies with me that
they don't know if they should do or not
but i like your reasons didn't you say
to her wouldn't you like to be in a film
that
people see yeah
i rest my case and then my big job on
this one was
was helping them cast a jude law to play
watson which wound up
being about the smartest thing we could
have done because he actually he is
he's really good he's very very funny so
great in this movie i i'm
really looking forward to people
enjoying him in it as well yeah because
normally he's just played as a bit of a
dunce
i mean really in the original books he's
uh he's a decorated soldier and he's a
bit of a womanizer and a gambler
and but they always cast him as some guy
who's got his foot in a waste basket and
kind of looks like a
schmuck next to sherlock probably to
make sure like look smarter
maybe we shouldn't
anyway jew's just great in the movie and
really fun and he's he was really fit
too and we had a great time i think it's
probably the real heart of the movie is
his relationship with
watson kind of like it was in the books
and it's sort of sweet how jealous you
are of the wife or the the beyonce
i'm feeling kind of sweet right now oh
yeah i got a nice feeling
good yeah how do you feel when people
talk about their feelings in england is
that all right
here it's a safe place thank you
another thing i know i'm gonna get this
along a lot
uh charlize oh i was just i was back
there freaking out you're like the first
person who said it
perfectly really yes i'll stop now i
won't
amazing 15 years and then you came along
yeah it all changes here by the way you
guys do you know each other outside of
being back there or on a sofa i know
john
and i don't know steve as long as i've
seen him on the telly you know that's
not real i know i know
and now it is jubilee weekend uh do you
plans anybody got plans
i uh i didn't realize it was jubilee
weekend but when i got here i got in
town a couple days ago and was invited
uh
i guess to sit next to the queen um
on the boat going down there that's
amazing
i'm not gonna do it
i don't i don't know her
or tiaras or no i don't know if you're
joking or not are you joking
oh no i'm completely joking
he has been invited on the boat i'm
really confused now are you feeling
right here on the boat
no well
no did you lie to him as well to me as
well yes
it's a john story it really is i didn't
even know there was going to be a boat
and these you were thinking
do they know i have an oscar
just another thing you don't have in
common with the queen
now charlize theron now we're
delighted you're here for all sorts of
reasons i'm so happy to be i'm a huge
fan
thank you
[Applause]
sarah jessica parker and you're wearing
jeans and a jumper
you idiot you look divine
no it has to say if you're going to
dinner people must feel threatened kind
of like we've got to look fabulous
because you're going to be there
no no first of all no one wants to have
dinner with me
and second of all um no i i i don't
i i don't think that that i have that
effect on people i think that
perhaps there's some lines that are
blurred that carrie bradshaw
yeah sarah jessica look what you
pressured me into wearing well you
literally
i don't know you guys you know each
other very well not well not
very well but well fairly well yes for
many years
many years very good now you're the same
age
[Applause]
i mean i know that's ridiculous to say
to somebody but it's true designers love
you
don't they i mean none of them have to
live with me they love them
i i like borrowing them a lot
but we've seen the pictures in the movie
section 32
the 80s yes this is hardly an iconic
moment
anyone remember that period don't deny
it god so do
don't you do you know what really dates
smoking i know
that was so important i wanted to make
sure we had that in there and i put my
mole back
oh and look and still a black string
your guests appear into the background
how weird little cameo sisters
because it must have been quite fun you
must've enjoyed all of that oh we loved
it digging in the old archives for some
horrible thing that you wish you never
had worn
well in the archives of things we should
never have worn dear god no no
need to join rivers
[Applause]
it's extraordinary i mean it was
extraordinary at the time i wore it to
an award show i hope you still have it
i have i saved them to sell on ebay does
that interest me because you both have
all these clothes
i mean do you keep all the clothes um
whatever they'll allow me whatever's
legal to keep i keep
i archive it i archive very things like
that which was bill blass who's no
longer alive
but the regular ones i give to guide
dogs to the blind once a year they have
a
a wonderful sale called posh they're
laughing but they
for once you're actually serious
people go this is great
they're all allowed but they do this big
sale once a year and i give it to them
most of the clothes
me too now
you left the stand up why did you stop
stand up
i because i'd been
very lonely and then suddenly i had
loads of superficial friends
there was that kind of rage about
certain things and then you're going
life's actually got really good and
as a character i kind of want to moan
about being
on the other side of the traps because
you kind of drawn into being
light entertainment and you you you are
mixing with the beautiful people whether
you like it or not
you know whatever and you're going i'm
nothing to be angry about at the moment
but now when you were doing this you did
work in terrible venues
uh what is this this this is a
vile story
i played a venue that once you went in
there
there was no toilets backstage and the
only way out was to the audience and i
was very much
i didn't like people to see me before
yeah
and kind of being a character was
hunched over a bottle of vodka and
you're going i i needed
the lou and i and i really need the loot
and i didn't want to burp the shark
because
you know it's edinburgh you've got the
one hour there's no way of taking a
break and it was a good show
i wasn't panning it out and the only
thing in the dressing room was a
pringles box
oh no not the mini one
[Applause]
no board i think somebody found this and
came up with the mini pack
because
[Applause]
with the longer pack i
manic this should have been on the
learning zone of the open university
i managed to turn it halfway down
create a catchment turkey
because if you've grown up and your
mum's a cleaner somebody's got to clean
up
after you right i didn't want this to be
anybody's results would say so
i had to
i don't remember in this but
when i was hunched over the pringles
back i was actually thinking
you're the professional
allowed me to this would be the best
dragon's den
ever
he's gonna allow me to tip it into the
remaining third of the pringles pack
then fold in the soiled earlier on top
which i'll keep the smelling and still
put the plastic
end on top
i wasn't proud but the best thing was it
fit in my pocket
so i did an entire gig
[Laughter]
three judges in from the penny here
just going what is the right time to go
it's one them boingy snakes
[Music]
you